third the large-scale climate changes
that come from the concentrations of
greenhouse gases here for example is how
global average surface temperatures have
changed over the last century the
temperature record is much less smooth
than the co2 concentration record you
see warming to about 1940 then little
change for a few decades then warming it
starts again in the late 70s slowing
down over the last decade why why does
the temperature record look so bumpy on
the co2 concentration record that drives
it looks so smooth there are several
reasons why the records look so
different first because many factors
push the climate one way or another a
big volcano for example but sulfuric
acid drops in the stratosphere that can
cool the whole planet for a year or two
the same fossil fuels that put carbon in
the atmosphere also pump out sulfur
pollution and other fine particulates
these pollutants stay in the atmosphere
for only a few weeks but they can change
the climate are reflecting more sunlight
back to space but unlike co2 that
accumulates slowly and spreads evenly
across the globe these pollutants have
varied from decade to decade and place
to place as countries have changed the
fuel they use perhaps from coal to gas
and the environmental cleanup
technologies that use putting scrubbers
on power plants or catalytic converters
on cars second the climate has lots of
natural fluctuations like the day-to-day
variability of weather that are random
internal dynamics of the climate system
what physicists like me like to call
noise the net result is that we can be
reasonably confident that much of the
warming over the past half-century is
due to human actions and very confident
that over the next century we will see a
great deal of warming due to human
action but it's still very hard or
outright impossible to know exactly what
the climate will do for one decade to
the next this brings us to our fourth
component climate impacts the many ways
in which these large-scale climate
changes influence human welfare
and the natural world many important
crops such as rice or wheat are damaged
by high temperatures during the
germination phase of their growing
season there's evidence that temperature
changes we've already seen from global
warming are cutting global crop
productivity perhaps by as much as five
percent compared to what it would have
been had temperatures not increased
although the overall crop productivity
has continued to rise as agricultural
methods have improved this as small as a
global average but by 2050 the impacts
will likely be much worse if we do not
restrain carbon emissions and climate
change over the next century warming
will accelerate the melting of the great
ice sheets in Greenland and Antarctica
raising global sea levels if we do not
restrain emissions sea levels might rise
by a meter by the end of the century and
several meters over the next few
centuries climate change is not just
warming it tends to make the dry places
drier and the wet places whether it
increases the intensity of the most
intense storms it will create a host of
other changes small and large from our
dramatic decrease in the amount of
Arctic sea ice to a loss of coral reefs
driven by the acidifying effects of co2
in ocean waters this and all other
predictions are subject to significant
uncertainty for example with
unrestrained emissions by the end of
this century sea level will likely rise
anywhere from half a meter to a meter
but there's a good chance perhaps fifty
percent odds that the rise will be
outside that range many impacts like
rising sea levels occur far in the
future sea level rise is relatively
small this entry for example but it gets
much bigger the next century if we can't
stop it